Traductor: Lidia Cámara de la Fuente
Revisor: Paulina Segovia
Probablemente conoces la sensación.
Tu teléfono emite
la última señal quejumbrosa,
y se corta en medio la llamada.
En ese momento, quizá deseas
lanzar la batería por los aires
más que cantar sus alabanzas.
Pero las baterías
son un triunfo de la ciencia.
Permiten que teléfonos inteligentes
y otras tecnologías existan,
sin estar enchufados a un enredo
infernal de cables eléctricos.
Pero incluso las mejores baterías
disminuirán su rendimiento diariamente
perdiendo poco a poco su función
hasta que finalmente mueren.
Pero, ¿por qué sucede esto,
y por qué las baterías al principio
almacenan tanta carga?
Todo comenzó en la década de 1780
con dos científicos italianos,
Luigi Galvani y Alessandro Volta,
y una rana.
La leyenda cuenta que mientras Galvani
estudiaba el anca de una rana,
rozó con un instrumento de metal
uno de los nervios de la rana,
dándole una sacudida
en músculos de las ancas.
Galvani llamó a esto
electricidad animal,
que asume que un tipo de electricidad
se almacena en la misma materia vital.
Pero Volta no estaba de acuerdo,
argumentando que el metal
hizo que el anca se contrajera.
El debate se resolvió finalmente
con el experimento pionero de Volta.
Se puso a prueba con una pila
de capas alternadas de zinc y cobre,
separados por papel o tela empapado
en una solución de agua salada.
Lo que pasó en la batería de Volta
es lo que hoy
los químicos llaman
oxidación y reducción.
El zinc se oxida, esto es,
pierde electrones,
que son captados
por los iones en el agua,
en un proceso llamado de reducción,
produciendo gas de hidrógeno.
Volta se habría sorprendido
al enterarse de esto último.
Pensó que la reacción
sucedía en el cobre,
en lugar de la solución.
No obstante, hoy honramos
el descubrimiento de Volta
dando el nombre de "voltio"
a la unidad estándar
de potencial eléctrico.
El ciclo de oxidación-reducción
crea un flujo de electrones
entre dos sustancias
y si enganchas una bombilla o aspiradora
entre ambas,
tendrás electricidad.
Desde 1700, los científicos
han mejorado el diseño de Volta.
Reemplazaron la solución química
con pilas secas
rellenas de pasta química,
pero el principio es el mismo.
Un metal se oxida,
enviando electrones a que hagan algo
antes de ser recuperados
por una sustancia que se está reduciendo.
Pero cualquier batería
tiene un suministro finito de metal,
y una vez que la gran parte
se ha oxidado, la batería se agota.
Así, las baterías recargables
dan una solución temporal a este problema,
haciendo el proceso
de oxidación-reducción reversible.
Los electrones pueden fluir de vuelta
en la dirección opuesta
al aplicar electricidad.
Al enchufar un cargador,
este atrae la electricidad
desde el enchufe
que conduce la reacción
para regenerar el metal.
poniendo más electrones a disposición
para la oxidación siguiente.
Pero incluso las baterías recargables
no duran siempre.
Con el tiempo,
la repetición de este proceso
provoca imperfecciones e irregularidades
en la superficie metálica
impidiendo su correcta oxidación.
Los electrones ya no están disponibles
para fluir en un circuito
y la batería muere.
Algunas baterías recargables morirán
tras solo cientos de ciclos
de descarga-recarga,
mientras baterías nuevas y avanzadas
pueden sobrevivir y funcionar
durante miles de ciclos.
Las baterías del futuro
podrán ser hojas ligeras y delgadas
que funcionan sobre los principios
de la física cuántica
y durarán cientos de miles
de ciclos de carga.
Pero hasta que los científicos
encuentren una forma
de aprovechar el movimiento
para recargar la batería,
como lo hacen los autos,
o adaptar paneles solares
en alguna parte del dispositivo,
Enchufar el cargador en la pared,
en lugar de gastar
una batería para cargar otra,
es la mejor opción para evitar
la señal de falta de batería.